bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france on s'en souvient l'instauration
du couvre-feu avaient provoqué de
violentes manifestations dans le pays
expliquez-nous pourquoi culturellement
cette mesure passe encore moins bien
qu'ailleurs au pays bas mais je pense
qu'à l'origine
personne n'aurait été vraiment contre et
il y a eu un espèce de comment je dois
dire une baisse de bourrage de crâne que
depuis la seconde guerre mondiale a été
jamais arrivé en fait dans la réalité va
commence presque tout le monde s'y
plient rentrer à 9 heures c'est pas très
très tôt et on voit les chiffres
bon là on a une dégradation un peu
déchiré c'est assez limité si je compare
à la france est donc bon a priori tout
le monde s'y fait si catastrophique
qu'on a bien voulu dire et pour le
médecin que vous êtes ce qu'on veut
reste quand même primordial pour
endiguer l'épidémie tout à fait tout à
fait bien et la mesure porte haut ses
fruits ce que vous avez des chiffres qui
montrent que effectivement l'améliorer
et efficace aux pays bas oui parce que
autant on a eu on a 23 % sur les quinze
derniers jours d'augmentation du nombre
de cas positifs un seder ça ne veut rien
dire quand on ne prend pas en compte le
nombre d'hospitalisations la mortalité
et les chiffres en réa et ceux ci sont
très stables ou un peu à la baisse
on travaille toujours en flux tendu mais
on arrive toujours maintenant rattraper
toutes les listes d'attentes de soins
réguliers
donc même si c'est beaucoup de travail
c'est stable comme ailleurs en europe on
imagine que ce sont les variants du
coronavirus qui suscite beaucoup
d'inquiétude oui a priori balle variés
anglais a l'air à peu près sûr compte
sous contrôle de ce que j'ai pu lire
encore cet après-midi et le vario sud
africain il ya quelques cas quelques cas
du vrai drian brésilien mais pour la
science est limité pour combien de temps
son c'est pas une espèce avoir été
limités on a aussi beaucoup d'espoirs
sur certaines nouvelles options
thérapeutiques et aussi d'avoir vacciner
un maximum de chant des nouvelles
options thérapeutiques
de quelle manière est ce qu'on en parle
dans le pays
sont sur le point d'aboutir qu'est ce
qui est en jeu en ce moment aux pays bas
eux
bahia la fameuse d'exams états zone qui
est à l'essai en phase précoce dans une
région des pays bas à domicile on a un
gros succès des hospitalisations à
domicile en surveillance continue de
saturation est aussi jaune aux thérapies
à domicile a priori ça marche très bien
ensuite dans on attend un peu quelques
nouvelles molécules on attend les
anticorps monoclonaux on attend
l'ivermectine on attend la colchicine
mais pour l'instant on a bon espoir avec
cette phase précoce de 2,2 d'examen et à
zoner soins à domicile très précoce
plutôt d'hospitaliser les patients et où
on fait la campagne de vaccination bat y
ait eu un flottement au début main
puisque on a été un peu les bons
derniers d'europe et on est en train de
bien rattraper chez les gens âgés chez
les gens à risque personnel médical
j'étais moi même vacciné avant-hier donc
ça ça a l'air de bien se passer des
instants les gens âgés les gens arrivent
seront vaccinés on verra une nette
baisse de la mortalité et aussi ceux des
hospitalisations pour qu'un oeuf et la
population joue le jeu de la vaccination
aux pays bas oui on a quelques
réticences dans ce qu'on appelle la
ceinture biblique des pays-bas banque
est une région qui s'étend de la zélande
à la la frontière allemande où les gens
sur des principes religieux refusent
plutôt la vaccination en général
hormis sa non les gens se laissent
vacciner ça se passe très très bien
alors en dernier mot si vous le voulez
bien sûr le contexte électoral avec des
élections législatives dans trois
semaines
vous êtes médecin de vous est aussi
citoyen on imagine que la gestion de la
pandémie est l'un des enjeux de ce
scrutin
oui et nous j'ai un peu l'impression que
tout le monde est en train de jouer un
peu la sécurité dans ces élections qui
sont dans les résultats sont un petit
peu sans surprise
à moins que mais bon ça y'a pas une
grande grande motivation chez les gens à
suivre ces élections n'a pas
l'impression que ça m'occupe beaucoup
les discussions
merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
réagir sur notre antenne xavier à
fallières anesthésiste à l'hôpital de
d'ordre est aux pays-bas